un de paris à montpellier en passant par
metz dunkerque toulouse marseille on va
voir on va se rendre du côté de rennes
où là bas aussi dans la rue en a
manifesté plus de 2000 personnes pour
étaient sur place pour défendre
l'hôpital public dans le cadre donc de
cette journée de mobilisation nationale
contrairement à la capitale sur 13000
cette passion elle s'est déroulée
vous voyez dans le calme on va écouter
la parole du personnel soignant présent
là bas on a été soutenu par la
population n'a été soutenue par le
gouvernement beaucoup beaucoup de
discours et là il ya un retour à la
normale trois mois après nous on attend
voilà d'avoir des vraies mesures qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
prises en charge pour nous pas pour le
patient pour la santé publique en fait
faut savoir que les salaires sont quand
même gelé depuis dix ans donc nous on
n'avait jamais eu d'augmentation de
salaire pour vous donner un exemple ça
fait 12 ans que j'affirme hier je suis
payé 1780 euros net par mois en étant
titulaire depuis plus de dix ans et
ayant travaillé en week end
ces médailles on a décidé d'être à 100
mais symboliquement un objet de
revendications puisque évidemment par
rapport aux besoins réels de l'hôpital
elle ne servira à rien les choses qui
vont nous servir
c'est plus de lits plus de postes les
recrutements massifs pour faire face à
hawk aux besoins des populations
évidemment des salaires 300 euros contre
des touches